hi my name is Jeff wall
j-e-f-f-w-a-l-l I'm a sergeant with the
north Las Vegas Police Department here
to tell you about an officer-involved
shooting that happened tonight September
24th 2022. at about 10 14 PM officers
were dispatched to the 4300 block of
westmere Avenue near Grand Teton and
Aviary way
caller reported that a unknown man was
in the backyard of a house with a long
metal pole and he attempt appeared to be
attempting to break into the house
the caller confronted the man
who asked him do you want to die
the caller reported that the man
appeared to be either intoxicated or
high on drugs
when officers arrived at about 10 17 PM
they located the man and he was armed
with a rifle at about 10 30 PM officers
reported that shots had been fired
the man had been shot at least one time
medical personnel were called
immediately and officers rendered
life-saving efforts
and the man was transported to UMC
trauma where he was pronounced deceased
no other persons were injured during
this shooting
the identity of the person deceased
would be released by The Clark County
coroner's office after proper
notifications next of kin
and the identity of the officer involved
will be released by the department after
48 hours pursuant to our department
policy procedure